lanzando acusaciones desde el hospital
el ex Primer Ministro Pakistán y brancan
habló por primera vez desde el atentado
que sufrió el jueves en un mitching
contó lo ocurrido durante al ataque y
señaló como responsables a varios
miembros del actual gobierno de haber
intentado matarlo nombró específicamente
al Primer Ministro ses basarif al
ministro del interior ranas anaula y los
servicios de inteligencia pero no aportó
pruebas
en primer lugar ranas Por qué ranas han
aula hizo el plan porque ranas es un
asesino rana sanaula y se va a salir
los dos funcionarios rechazaron las
acusaciones y pidieron una investigación
independiente sobre el tiroteo y brancan
llevaba una semana encabezando marchas
para obtener la organización de
elecciones anticipadas el jueves en una
de ellas en guajirabat un individuo le
disparó a la pierna en total el atentado
dejó un muerto y al menos Yes heridos
cuando estaba en el contenedor de
repente hubo una Ráfaga de balas las
balas me dieron en la pierna y me caí
este viernes sus partidarios organizaron
protestas en todo el país bloquearon
carreteras y se enfrentaron a las
fuerzas de seguridad
solo tenía una agenda conseguir una
fecha para las elecciones y celebrarlas
la marcha real continuará hasta que se
dé la hora y la fecha de las elecciones
el atentado aumentó aún más las
tensiones del país sumido en una
profunda crisis política desde que Khan
fue expulsado del poder tras una moción
de censura en el congreso y
posteriormente
descalificado por la comisión electoral
Para ocupar cargos públicos durante 5
años